Chris Hardwick: Let's bring out
the director of Thor Ragnarok,
an amazing genius that I've been fortunate
enough to get to know the past few years
Mr. Taika Watiti!
[Audience cheering and clapping]
Also, a man by the name of
Chris Hemsworth!
[Audience cheering and clapping]
Tom Hiddleston!
Mark Ruffalo!
[Audience cheering and clapping]
Cate Blanchett!
A Jeff Goldblum has arrived,
a wild Jeff Goldblum has been spotted.
[Audience cheering and clapping]
Also, Tessa Thompson!
Karl Urban!
[Audience cheering and clapping]
And Rachel House!
Excellent.
Your 'Thor: Ragnarok' cast!
[Audience cheering]
Chris Hemsworth: We're here!
Hardwick: Congratulations. Thank you guys
for being here. Thank you so much for being here.
Hemsworth: Thanks for having us.
Hardwick: Uh, Mr. Hemsworth,
So, Thor does not have his hammer.
He does not have Asgard. What --
Hemsworth: Or his hair.
Hardwick: He doesn't have hair,
that he normally would have.
Hemsworth: No. Getting old, fell out.
[Audience chuckles]
Hardwick: So this looks like a very different Thor,
totally, and character wise, with Thor stories.
What's going on?
What's going on with him right now?
Hemsworth: Uh, midlife crisis, I think.
[Audience chuckles]
Um --
Well, I've played this character five times,
uh, this is Marvel's 167th film or something.
[Audience chuckles]
Um, and --
Well, me personally, I got a bit bored of myself
and thought 'we gotta try something different.'
Spoke with Taika, spoke with Kevin, and all of us agreed if we're going to make a third 'Thor,'
we have to really push the envelope and experiment,
and take it to another level, so,
that was what this film was, you know?
Cut his hair, break his hammer,
change his clothes, change the world,
And I think that's what you're going
to see and be excited about,
it's something incredibly unique and different for,
not only the Thor world, but the Marvel universe.
[Audience cheering]
Hardwick: And so --
Because he's so used to
being in charge. I mean like, he's --
never really seems like
he has to break much of a sweat.
And this -- but from
what we've seen so far --
Hemsworth: No, he gets
his ass kicked in this film.
Mainly by the bloke
a couple of seats away from me.
[Audience clapping and cheering]
They have a good little rumble, yeah.
Hardwick: And Taika, I was so excited when
I found out you were doing this movie,
because 'What We Do In The Shadows'
is one of the great --
[Audience clapping and cheering]
You and Jemaine together
are an incredible combination,
and to hear that you were going --
What is the transition like from going from
a film like 'What We Do In The Shadows,'
which is an intimate movie that
you worked on for a long time,
to this, you know, mega-tentpole with
a character that everyone already knows?
Taika Waititi: Um, yeah, bit of food,
for us now, on set.
And, um --
You know, I just --
just like, um --
You know, Chris was bored of what he was up to,
I was also bored of what he was up to,
and um --
[Audience laughs]
And when he reached out,
he rea -- I just saw a friend in need, and, uh --
[Audience laughs and 'aww's]
You know. And that's just
who I am, that's my nature.
[Mark Ruffalo laughs]
Waititi: You know, if you need help,
if you need me to pull you from
the dark depths, I'm there, for you.
And if that means me having to take on
a tentpole movie like this,
I'll do it, I'll take one for the team.
[Audience cheers]
So, it's really that.
I was just trying to help my mate out.
Um --
The [indistinct] of how different it was,
moving from a tiny little film to a giant one,
I feel like --
There's a lot more pressure,
obviously, but, um,
at the end of the day,
you know, I keep saying this,
whatever's inside that rectangle
is all that matters.
You know, there might be
500 more people on the crew, but um,
you know, as long as
the actors are good, in their lines,
and, um, saying them, convincingly,
that's all that matters.
Doesn't matter what the budget is.
And --
Most of these people
did not learn their lines.
[Audience and panel laugh]
Hardwick: Ok, it just got very serious for a second.
Let's call people out. Let's make it, uh --
[Laughter]
Uh, Tom Hiddleston, ah, who --
[Audience clapping and cheering]
Who -- couple years ago,
you came out here in full costume.
There was a full production.
[Audience cheering]
It was one of the most memorable
and incredible moments of Comic-Con,
and -- you had fun, right? How could you
not have fun with that? Was that --
Tom Hiddleston: It was
a unique experience, and,
for which I will be
eternally grateful to Hall H.
[Audience cheering]
Hardwick: So what what has Loki
been up to at this point?
Hiddleston: Well, it's been
four years, and, um --
If you saw 'Thor: The Dark World,' you will know that
at the end of that film, Loki is on the throne of Asgard,
pretending to be Odin.
So Thor comes home, and, uh,
things are a little different in Asgard.
Um --
Loki has directed most of his energies
into narcissistic self-glorification.
Um --
Not so much time on good governance.
Um, but Ragnarok is coming and, uh --
Loki's allegiances have always
been slightly unpredictable,
and he's still the God of Mischief.
And where -- what his part is in all of that,
You'll just have to wait and see.
Hardwick: Alright. I feel like they will,
I feel like they're going to see it.
I feel like this crowd is probably gonna
see this movie. I'm gonna take a guess.
[Audience cheering]
I feel like they're on board with it.
Feel like they're on board with it.
Uh, Mark!
Mark Ruffalo: Uh, yeah.
[Audience clapping and cheering]
I'll go see it. I'm gonna see it.
I'll see it.
Hardwick: You're gonna see it?
Ruffalo: I'll -- I'm gonna see it.
Hardwick: Can you pick me up? Can you take me --
can you out to see the movie? I want to see the movie.
What -- can we talk about
the evolution of the Hulk a little bit?
Ruffalo: What is it?
Hardwick: The evolution of the Hulk.
The Hulk is a movie that you --
you're a character in the --
Ruffalo: Oh!
Well, it's a little different Hulk
than we've seen. He, um --
Hulk refuses to turn back into Banner.
And he's actually enjoying
his time on Sakaar,
because he is a Gladiator Champion
of the world of Sakaar.
Which means he kicks a lot of "A".
[Audience chuckles]
Because it says right here, 'please be aware that many members of your audience may be under the age of 18.'
Hardwick: It is very nice of you to honor that.
Literally nobody else has been honoring that.
Ruffalo: He kicks a lot of "A".
Hardwick: Nice.
And and he's enjoying his life for once,
and he'll be damned
if he's going to go back to Banner.
Hardwick: Again with the harsh language.
I don't know why you had to take it so fluffy [?] there.
[Audience laughs]
Ruffalo: Is 'damn' a swear word?
Hardwick: I don't know, probably not.
I just think, kids, you can't
offend them at all anymore,
because of the internet, it doesn't even
matter anymore, everyone knows everything.
[Audience chuckles]
Ahh --
So is he sort of -- he is kind of a perma-Hulk at this point?
Ruffalo: He's a little perma-Hulked.
Hardwick: Yeah.
Ruffalo: Um -- and,
He's starting to be able --
because he's been the Hulk for two years now,
he has a vocabulary of a two-year-old.
[Audience chuckles]
So we have a speaking Hulk.
Can I say that?
Waititi: Well, too late.
Ruffalo: Alright, sorry.
[Audience laughs]
We may or may not
have a speaking Hulk, in 'Thor 3,'
where everyone may or may not die.
[Audience and panel laughter]
Hardwick: Fair enough. That wraps it up.
Ah, Cate. How did you come
into the Marvel Universe?
And what was your --
[Audience cheering]
What -- what --
what threw you in --
I mean seriously, yeah, seriously.
Seriously, seriously.
Cate Blanchett: A sort of happy accident.
I sort of live in the same continent
as Taika, and the flight was cheap,
so he came over and --
[Hardwick laughs]
Waititi: I just saw a friend in need.
[Audience laughter]
You know? Someone just
reaching out for [indistinct].
A whisper in the dark,
just, yeah, needing help.
Blanchett: Yeah, no, I'm grateful.
No, I mean -- look, it's -- it's, um --
it's a universe that I've sort of been
happily dragged into, because of my kids.
And yeah, so yeah,
and to work with Taika, and these guys,
and gal-s [emphasizes the plural],
was, yeah, pretty exciting.
Hardwick: Pretty amazing.
And then, uh, Jeff Goldblum, who --
[Audience cheering and clapping]
The Grandmaster.
If I'm not mistaken, you're the -- yes.
Jeff Goldblum: No, you were gonna say.
Hardwick: You're the Collector's brother,
is that not, uh, accurate?
Goldblum: He looks like what?
Hardwick: The Coll -- you're --
[Audience chuckles]
Blanchett: It's hard to hear.
Hardwick: [increases volume]
Oh, it is hard to hear?
[shouting]
You are the Collector's brother!
Goldblum: Yes, I'm the Collector's brother.
Benicio Del Toro. Yes, yes.
[Audience cheering]
We're very old, we were -- we were elders --
we're elders of the universe.
We came about shortly after the Big Bang.
Ruffalo: So did the rest of us.
[Hardwick and audience laugh]
Hardwick: Aww, come on.
It's really funny, you make that joke, but
you say "A" instead of ass. That's really funny.
[Audience chuckles]
Goldblum: My character, yeah, we're all the --
we're the oldest living creatures in the universe.
Yeah, oldest living race,
they call us in the thing.
We were here
shortly after the Big Bang.
Grandmaster, and, um,
and my brother Collector. That's right.
Hardwick: Excellent.
Goldblum: And now I run -- [chuckles]
And now I rule on this planet Sakaar,
and put together games, mostly.
I'm a games -- I love games.
[Audience chuckles]
And fighting, fighting games,
and I put together,
I don't want to give anything away,
but the great, great match between
Hulk and the new Thor.
[Audience clapping and cheering]
I put that together.
For your entertainment and pleasure.
Hardwick: Can you hear me down there, Tessa?
Can you hear me here?
Tessa Thompson: Yeah, I can hear you.
Hardwick: Oh ok, great. Ah, welcome, welcome.
[Audience clapping and cheering]
Thompson: Thanks very much.
Hardwick: So what can you say about Valkyries, or
anything you can say about Valkyrie, for people?
Thompson: Uh, you know,
I was just another friend in need.
[Hardwick laughs]
Waititi: You're welcome.
[Audience chuckles]
Thompson: No, I'm thankful.
Uh, she's an elite warrior of Asgard,
who's hanging out on Sakaar
for reasons that I can't really elaborate on.
And she has a relationship
with the Grandmaster.
It's not romantic.
I mean, maybe it
used to be. Who knows?
Um --
[Audience laughs]
He's a friend from work.
And, uh --
I just -- she just picks up
little pieces around town
and maybe an interesting
one of them happens to be a big...
God-like thing. Um -- yeah, right?
And so she brings him
to the Grandmaster, and then,
it takes us off on our story.
Hardwick: Excellent.
Karl Urban, who's, uh, Skurge.
[Audience clapping and cheering]
Karl Urban: Comic-Con, how are you?
Are you out of your Vulcan mind?
[Audience clapping and cheering]
Hardwick: Ah, yeah.
Urban: [indistinct] we?
Hardwick: Cross the streams, man.
I love it. Cross the streams.
[Audience laughs]
They -- when did you guys shoot this movie?
Because they said you shaved your head,
and you already have -- like, you're that masculine,
that your hair immediately just, whoof.
Urban: Yeah, uh, I was in the same boat
with everybody else, actually,
I was actually on vacation, and I received a call from
Taika, who was in Australia, deep behind enemy lines.
[Hardwick and audience laugh]
Saying, 'mate, uh, I need help.'
And so literally, that is why I joined this cast.
Uh, so it's --
Waititi: Karl's from New Zealand, like me,
and, you know,
surrounded by so many Australians,
it's just the accent, it's just --
Urban: Yeah. It's a little bit --
Waititi: -- drilled, I think, drilled into
the side of the head, all day long.
[Audience laughs]
Like a glass bottle, full of nails,
just shake them in your ears, like all day.
Urban: You know,
I almost didn't make it to set,
because when I came into Australia, the customs
officer asked me if I had a criminal record,
and I said, 'Oh mate, I didn't know
I still needed one to get in!'
[Hardwick and audience laugh]
Chris Hemsworth,
your great-granddaddy stole an apple,
[Audience chuckles]
got caught, and was
sent on a boat, right?
Hemsworth: Thank God,
thank God for that, too.
Hardwick: Breaking news! Australia declares war
on New Zealand, tomorrow at 11.
Hemsworth: Yeah, we're just kind of bridging the gap
between New Zealand and Australia, for the moment.
As you can see, we're sitting a lot closer
to each other, than shooting at --
Waititi: Bringing two cultures together,
the warring tribes of Australia and New Zealand.
Hemsworth: It's all over. In the past.
Waititi: Long [?] peace.
[Audience laughs]
Hardwick: Make! A! Baby!
Make! A! Baby!
[Audience chuckles]
Hemsworth: We will.
We made a movie, instead.
Hardwick: And then Rachel House,
who has a -- a history of --
[Audience and panel clapping and cheering]
-- working with Taika, and --
Rachel House: None of you know who I am.
Hardwick: -- people who don't know,
can you talk about some of your --
House: It's very nice
that you're cheering. Hello.
Hardwick: Hello.
House: Hello!
Hardwick: Can you talk about
your history a little bit, working with Taika?
House: So I've been in 4 out of 5
of his films that he's made, yeah.
So he just pulled me along
for the accent, and for the ride.
Waititi: Yeah, Rachel's like my good-luck charm,
I try and put her in everything I do.
'Cause, uh, she's...
you just gotta see her, she's awesome.